deux temps forts aujourd'hui dans ce
procès des attentats de janvier 2015
tout d'abord l'audition dali paul at il
s'agit aujourd'hui d'ailleurs des
enquêtes de personnalité c'est à dire
qu'on ne parle pas des fêtes mais juste
du parcours de vie des accusés à l'ipo
lattes est censé être le complice dames
et 10 et coulibaly c'est le seul
d'ailleurs qui poursuivi pour complicité
il encourt la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
on lui reproche d'avoir cherché
transporter stocker des armes pour le
compte desdits coulibaly il est apparu
très véhément ce matin très désagréable
même avec la cour et le il ya eu des
moments un peu houleux dans ce procès
jusqu'ici est très calme au sujet des
questions sur la religion il faut savoir
que les questions sur l'art la religion
et la radicalisation des prévenus
présents car ils ne sont pas tous
présents incertains sont en fuite et
bien seront abordés plus tard quand les
faits seront abordés et puis deuxième
temps fort évidemment l' enquête de
personnalité dyad boumédiène c'est la
seule femme de ce procès femme en fuite
et bien sa soeur est venue témoigner
pour expliquer le parcours de vie de
cette femme qui a été placée à la suite
de la mort de sa mère je parle bien sûr
d'être boumédiène la compagne de mehdi
coulibaly une femme perturbée qui s'est
progressivement replié dans la religion
mais ni sa soeur ni son ami une amie qui
est venue également témoigné en gilbert
aujourd'hui qu'elle même avait une
pratique très rigoriste de la religion
ne comprenne ce qu'il s'est passé n'ont
pas senti la menace venir la soeur d'aya
de boumédiène a expliqué que les crimes
de charlie hebdo des attentats étaient
abominables insoutenable et quant à
l'ami d'ayette boumédiène elle n'a pas
non plus compris à quel moment ça là
cela allait déraper
et puis il faut dire que ayad boumédiène
a donné des signes de vie jusqu'en
octobre 2019 à ces deux témoins dont
qu'elle était à l'époque dans un camp
donc elle est encore vivante en octobre
2019 pour l'ami daihatsu médiane et bien
comédienne semblait totalement
embrigader elle était pour elle le bijou
de l'état islamique elle se pensait le
bijou de l'état islamique elle était
totalement sur une autre planète dans
une autre dimension donc difficile
d'expliquer de rendre compte
difficile d'apporter des réponses au
fait que amedi coulibaly et ayad
boumediane ait pu basculer dans une
telle folie voilà pour aujourd'hui pour
le résumé de ces audiences ici au
tribunal de paris